this is a Senegalese loot elude yeah
what do you do with it well you know
it's used for fertility rituals it's
carved from deer wood they used one
every seven years and what do you do
with it you put your weed in there the
waterboy Adam Sandler my good buddy
called me I was doing some TV show or
something I said we got a little
something for you it was just just one
line but he said we'll do it it'll be
funny and we'll figure it out I wasn't
what's the line you can do it no like I
wanted what is it I don't get it you're
fake we'll figure it out just get out
here you know come on he just had you
know different setups for you can do it
you can do it than that I just remember
it was just it had his silliness to it
and I think it was similar thing for the
character I did on Saturday Night Live
that was a so similar idiot and that
would have a nice repetition and a
rhythm to it and then you see him
several times and it would be each time
a different situation saying some stupid
[Applause]
two weeks before the movie opened he
called me you know because I still
didn't quite get what we were doing out
there let me sit Robby said hey in two
weeks the movies gonna come out you're
not gonna be able to go anywhere without
hearing you can dude and I'm like and
I'm everything oh maybe he's right it's
been 20 years now still happening S&M I
think I saw Steve Martin performing in
San Francisco and I was 13 and I
remember like he was in the same room as
me and it's huge out of time and I
remember looking to go okay well he's a
person he's in the same room with me he
figured it out so maybe I could figure
it out and that's that was but as
intellectual as I got with the whole
thing and I just started writing jokes
my sketch is like a sprint it's just
like you run for two minutes as hard as
you can and hopefully gay a few laughs
people find it funny then they repeat it
I was up in upstate New York
in Rochester New York my girlfriend at
the time took me to this place called
momma songs and near to that place was
this African antiquity store
any go let's check this out I go in
there and look like everything is like
drums Michael showels and like little
drawers everything in there is like
something like where my brother would
hide his weed so I went up too late and
I just took a drumline where's the weed
going here well you know alright yeah
it's just looking me like I was a crazy
person
oh it's from New Guinea it's a
ceremonial spiritbox wow that's cool
what do you do with it you put your weed
in there Lou Morton came up with some
great [ __ ] for that this is a sin again
Lee's loot elude yeah what do you do
with it well you know it's used for
fertility rituals it's carved from deer
would they use one every seven years and
what do you do with it you put your weed
in there that's to me the comedy stuff
is a rhythm with it hopefully an
absurdist progression that leads to some
places silly silly is king chris farley
i've used to member the first time I met
him he was checking in this hotel
because I'd never saw a picture I've
never seen him before and I didn't know
it was him but I was checking into I
need a smoking room cuz I like to smoke
and I don't want to pay the extra $50
Moken room so I need the smoking room
please you know or the smokers cuz I
like the smoke I like to have smoke and
so I'm requesting right now smoking room
and I went who is this [ __ ]
and he said I'll check up the name is
Farley checking a little roll Bittinger
and there you'll find the name Farley in
ref Farley FA are Lee and I went like oh
hey Chris I'm Rob and I'll be working
with you this year and then we went out
to a Mexican restaurant called Jose and
I never went back that restaurant after
that evening because we were eating and
drinking and then the next thing you
know drinking and then the next thing
you know drinking it was 11 shots of 11
beers he's standing on the table naked
and he was hilarious but frightening
because he wasn't a famous naked guy he
was just a fat not famous naked guy
drunk and you got me but at the same
time he was just hysterical II funny I
couldn't help but laugh but I also never
went back that restaurant and they never
wanted
to ever come back to the restaurant he's
a guy that like there's not gonna be
another guy like that everybody said
he's funny but he really was funny he
just you know do things that other
people wouldn't do sweetest nicest guy
you'd most imagine surf ninjas we're
over in Thailand it's like Oh God
they made the costumes in LA they didn't
realize it's gonna be literally 98
degrees before 9 a.m. so got up to like
110 115 degrees I remember like Leslie
Nielsen
the guy from Naked Gun we almost killed
him because he was in a bear outfit like
Oh No and I remember like we didn't have
any money for a boat supposed to be a
scene in a boat Neela's eurozone would
just get somebody to paint it I think
we're in trouble
demolition me the producers Joel silver
he said you have a terrible manager you
know why I couldn't believe how hard it
was to get you being this thing I know
because there's no lines is there's
nothing there's not a role here yeah but
you don't figure out the first day on it
a Sandra Bullock came up to me she was
doing it as perfect Stallone impression
loser oh good I've never seen a woman
you know doing semester still on
impression it's a place where you're
supposed to have the toilet paper you
got this little shelf with three
seashells on he doesn't know how to use
the three seashells
[Laughter]
well three seashells is a type of toilet
paper - there you go everybody knows you
just not use it three seashells use the
three seashells you'd open it up and
then toilet paper comes down how do you
through zoo jobs we're gonna lift them
up a hassle it's right underneath their
Seinfeld
so they had this thing of Bob you know
which is the guy who was like deaf but
not really deaf and I said it's a Larry
and we're like if my character deaf and
this thing you know well I got it I
don't know what do you think I didn't
write it
you wrote it I don't know I don't know
what's find out no you just say so I
never knew I got to watch the rehearsals
gonna stick around them all here for a
week right so much in Michael Richards
and Jerry do the scene in Jerry's
apartment and Michael Richards doing
this
kind of blocking jerry's way and doing
this and and the like
seem to be nervous and like I have to
say no one like Michael what were you
doing in that scene and he said well in
my mind I had farted and I didn't want
Jerry to go into that area that's a good
comic actors do they got stuff going on
in their head you know something's going
on but you don't know exactly what
they're always thinking you know and
Michael rich is one of those great guys
like that and then he told me hey great
to have you here this week Rob but uh
sorry this is not one of our better
episodes they're like what it's not what
it's not it's not Jerry it's not Big
Daddy he wanted me for one of the roles
and then the studio said no and they
gave it to Jon Stewart to play like the
dad you know I said don't worry about it
Adam that's fine hey no I'm we'll do
something else so now you know but the
last thing left was just a Chinese
delivery guy
and I went like dude I'm fine don't
don't worry buddy then come out we'll
make something of it I said this guy you
know it shouldn't be Chinese you should
be like some like Eastern European
Russian ish Kazakh Stan kind of guy
there was a guy that I knew who had a
baseball card shop his name is Yuri and
the area was the guy talked to like this
he's from Russia he's a guy that 20 talk
to you just made you feel horrible and I
thought well that's that's fun and then
well if you're a delivery guy in New
York
Griese Eastern European delivery guy
people won't even acknowledge you or
look at you and I kind of kind of made
me angry a little bit and I were like
well that's a good attitude you know
they had him would just say come on
we'll figure out I said there's no life
today just come out we'll figure out
something so all the lines in there he
would figure out the night before while
we were in a sauna together coming up
with jokes or whatever and then I would
come up with stuff off of his stuff and
it ended up being or like a really fun
role EEP keep help keep Papa Mama's
and truthfully it was necessary in that
role you know he just kind of adopted a
family and just kind of made it work and
then he just threw some funny stuff and
it was just adam ad-libbing and the me
ID living off his ID living and dennis
dugan being open enough to like yeah
that will work
you know I opened up the door Yoli
solder Ino you
Euler's order three piece of cheesecake
when you're doing a movie you got to get
the laughs wherever you can
deuce Bigalow I remember my career
several times being in the toilet cuz I
had some movies that did you know they
did okay that didn't do great she have
to come up with something else and I
remember like Adam was writing his own
movies he said just write your own movie
just write one and I said what about
what it's gonna have to figure out and
mm I don't know figure it out you know
Sam literally was in my apartment San
Francisco and I'm what no flipping the
TV and I see this movie Richard Gere and
it was like it doesn't seem to be like a
very believable movie where's this guy
these beautiful women need to hire a
gigolo you know because you know they
can't get a guy and there's like a you
know beautiful women didn't get a guy
anywhere this is a comedy it just isn't
a comedy yet and then we're like okay
alright I swear to God like most of my
ideas are not well thought-out that's
one of them again it's just a simple
idea and they just started writing this
thing about like a guy and I said if I
could just be like the most low level
like you know guy and they're trying to
think of what could it be like and if a
guy who's like you know cleans fish
tanks and that's this thing is like a
nerdy kind of guy that like he's really
good with fish but not with people and
you know it seemed like it simple enough
idea I remember I wrote 85 pages and I
was on a plane with Adam Sandler I said
you see what are you working on they let
me read it
let me you're eating just I was reading
and he's laughing laughing out loud
hysterically and I'm like he must like
it you know he's the first guy I'd ever
read and he said come eyes it's
hilarious and I said well I'm gonna go
home and finish it and he said hey
listen stay here let's have some fun and
then finished it after this week and
then I'll produce it and I went like wow
that my life just changed right now 50
first dates
when you're really famous movie star
like Adam you get to like show up on an
island somewhere and then you get the
whole place to yourself like a whole
Chateau or whatever the hell it is there
we're by ourselves they're like oh man
and then we're like kind of paranoid cuz
there just by ourselves didn't like
there was somebody working on the the
land or whatever you know I was right on
the beach let's go talk to that guy we
talked to that guy hey hey excuse me
what are you doing here what is your
name
and he turned over there and he had that
milky eye and go yeah my name is Lola
are you doing brother
Adam looked at me and said you're gonna
play him in a movie and I remember they
he's gonna do it
and I knew it and he you know and he did
okay this is her start beating me up
make it look good
so they had this shitty car and it goes
about 8 miles an hour and an uphill
about 4 miles an hour so we're on the
side of the road she's getting and
there's like I'm supposed to pretend to
be mugging Adam Sandler and then we're
waiting for the car to come up and so we
had to ad-lib a little scene and then an
up stayin in the movie cuz it was funny
is they you come here and make us make
my see stop cleaning your hotel room eat
a pineapple lean on it and what does
that have to do with anything and it
just gave us a little bit cuz you can
have something on paper but like and
then when you get out to do it he might
you just make a little hole you got to
fill that hole hole be something funny
and ended up you know being appropriate
for the moment and then she comes with
this [ __ ] back
yeah the stunt guy said hey you want me
to tell uh he looked at me what though
you know I they said they want me to
tell drew to take it easy honey a little
bit because it was like a bat but you
know what the rubber around it it's a
[ __ ] bat right I said now let her way
along me she seems to be enjoying it so
as soon as she was hating me I just
started just running and I just remember
seeing like them cameraman didn't
lifting the huge old-fashioned film
cameras and then following me in the
chase and the you know drew very
instinctual actress wanted to keep
beating me so she chased me and then she
just kept hitting me and then it ended
up being like from a laughs to a big
laugh to a roar so when we screened it
you couldn't hear the screen anymore cuz
Yanis laughing so loud you dreamed for
moments like that we talked to Lula and
like bring your family about have dinner
was telling we're going to this movie
and it's gonna be fun and they brought
like 40 people we had they're like oh
okay it's 40 40 he's got a big family
you know
but the island people were super nice
they loved the idea of the movie and
they make the iana look beautiful and
paradise like it is you know so that was
a magical time
I now pronounce you chuckling yeah yeah
I mean to me this whole thing about like
you're not allowed to play something
outside your race well I think there's
only one race the human race and I think
you know if I'm gonna only play the
characters that are part Filipino and
part German and Russian and Portuguese
then like what what was that guy you
know I think you should be able to
allowed to play anything there's a
brilliant makeup guy his name was Kazu
he would do amazing prosthetics I mean
the best
and so Kazu who's Japanese an incredible
artist he did my makeup and so I thought
well if Kazi was okay with it how could
anybody else I'm problem you know and he
had me you know do a very funny Asian
you know character the fun thing about
that was like I like to have characters
I completely hide behind where nobody
knows it's me and it was perfect because
you couldn't tell it's being a scene
with Adam Sandler Kevin James where they
were laughing and couldn't stop laughing
and they get so frustrated because
they're like yeah you know it's just and
haven't I got both you bastards I get
both of you
Dennis Dougan came up to me then it's
doing the director and he said you come
up with something here like you know
what they would say at a wedding like
you know it's a circle it's not
beginning there's not it's not like a
whole nut you know a triangle could you
get stuck in the corner there's no
beginning and there's no end cuz it's a
sir
that ridiculous six well that was like
the first movie that Netflix made and is
with Adam Sandler who's like the most
watched guy in the world he wanted to
bring a group of guys together and a
bunch of brothers and he had some great
scenes and he wanted to make a Western
that's tough to make a Western it's
expensive to make a Western you got to
go somewhere to make a Western so we
went out to beautiful Santa Fe New
Mexico and and made this thing and you
know of course you know I don't get a
horse I get a burro there was this
beautiful cinematographer I worked with
Carlos hit algo Valdez from Mexico City
he's a classic J Longo and he's the
voice that would wake up dead people in
the morning once this year
camasta how are you hey amigo
so I said okay that's the voice I don't
know if I could do it the whole time
this is the Mexican voice for sure and
then we did the first scene and
again his Adam and I doing a scene
together it's when we meet I've been
combing the borough and I see him and he
says you know wait we're brothers my
brother so I hug him and I still have to
brush up my hand so I just start
brushing him and I just remember like
laughing on the other side you know I
got you again you [ __ ] and he
kept it in the movie you know and I
remember I'm just hugging him and I just
I think I tried to eat his shoulder at
one point it's instinctual you know we
just seemed funny to us at the time and
if it makes us laugh it's got a good
chance to making other people laugh and
that was like kind of spanned like a
20-year period of making movies with
Adam real Rob an interesting play you
know for entertainment is to do a show
where the audience you don't know how
much is real and how much isn't real I
wasn't fulfilled with the sitcom that I
got to do on one of the network's
and I said let's do this we decided to
just make the first pilot and his I just
make the whole series and then we'll
find a place for it and then Netflix
bought it they paid for the second
season which was like amazing the second
season every episode is 30 minutes and
it you can really do something you can
actually take an audience someplace and
one of the things that Netflix insists
on and all these streaming services
people want to see an arc they want to
see where it's gonna go so you could
take an audience someplace the best
compliment you can ever have is we watch
the show in two days so you know it's a
pleasure and I look forward to doing
some more stuff and maybe even making a
few movies for them
[Music]